[Music]  et can confirm Adam Levine and his wife  Behati Prinsloo have welcomed their  second child into the world a daughter  named Geo grace Levine the maroon 5  frontman and the Victoria's Secret Angel  are also parents to a 16 month old  daughter dusty Rose who was born in  September 2016 Friz liu announced her  second pregnancy on social media in  September just ahead of Dusty's first  birthday with this baby bump shot riding  round two two months later the couple  decided to reveal the sex of their  latest bundle of joy it is a girl Levine  and Prinsloo tied the knot in 2014 in  San josé del Cabo Mexico after getting  engaged a year before and in 2016 the  voice coach opened up to et about  becoming a first-time parent how are you  prepping for baby girl oh man you ready  yeah you'll be a great dad  I think so I was coming we were born to  be a parent that's what we're here for  really yeah all the other is great but  it's not what we're here for  [Music]